[Aplausos]
[Música]
o
eu queria convidar vocês pra fazer uma
reflexão
como será que são produzidas todas as
coisas que a gente consome e utiliza o
nosso dia aqui se vocês olharem aqui ao
seu redor
provavelmente tudo que está proposto
aqui foi feito em uma grande fábrica de
uma grande indústria uma grande máquina
que por um lado com kospi milhares de
objetos iguais e pelo outro ela cospe
milhares de toneladas de rejeitos que a
gente não sabe muito bem o que fazer com
eles depois um
será que não dá pra fazer diferente como
indivíduo
o que a gente poderia fazer para mudar o
jeito que as grandes indústrias podem
fabricar os seus projectos 1 por conta
da minha posição da minha iniciação no
movimento maker há 15 anos eu aprendi
que a gente pode fazer muito
eu queria dividir aqui com vocês essas
idéias começando contando uma história
em 1994
eu li os livros um cara chamado eric
drexler que é um cientista do e mate e
um dos pais da nanotecnologia o treco
escreveu num desses livros ele fazia
previsões e cenários incríveis sobre
como seria o futuro da humanidade
o desenvolvimento da nanotecnologia uma
das coisas que mais me causou impressão
foi a descrição que ele fazia de como as
coisas vão ser produzidas no futuro
ele faz a descrição de uma grande
indústria onde a toda a área de produção
cabia num espaço um pouco maior do que
uma sala de estar
e nessa sala de estar tinha uma grande
piscina interligada diversos tanques
nesse estanques tinham todo o material
necessário para construir qualquer coisa
era um carbono fibras estruturais ou
motores pré montados alguns momentos
depois de algumas horas depois do
comando dado no computador para começar
a fabricação energia magicamente dessas
piscinas os produtos prontos acabados
prontos para o uso
a aplicação era extremamente limpa e sem
rejeitos
primeiro tive que ler algumas vezes para
tentar entender como aquilo funcionava
porque não cabia na minha cabeça
produtos que saiu de uma piscina depois
eu pensei beleza ficção científica mas
pro trétis ter isso é possível devido ao
sol mas não máquinas que ele chamava de
moléculas em blitz
essas máquinas muito pequena se imagina
que nessas oficinas existiam essas
máquinas muito pequenas do tamanho de
uma bactéria existiam milhões e milhões
dessa linha dentro
essas máquinas tinham capacidade de se
auto replicar e além disso ela seguiu
instruções para posicionar precisamente
átomo por átomo molécula por molécula
daquele objeto que estava sendo
construído até a gente ter o objeto
final
além disso isso só é possível porque
toda a informação necessária para
construir esse objeto estava embutida no
próprio material
pensando assim é um pouco difícil de
entender mas tem uma coisa que todo
mundo sabe
ou todo mundo conhece e tem um princípio
de funcionamento muito semelhante
um desses blocos de brinquedo está
embutida toda a informação necessária
para construir qualquer coisa ou seja a
sua forma o número de encaixes ou mesmo
a sua cor
tudo isso faz com que eu possa montar e
desmontar esse brinquedo indefinidamente
e por isso que a informação está
embutida no material
a versão mais atual da ideia do drexler
é trazer o que acontecia nessa piscina
por uma máquina do tamanho de um micro
ondas mas que seguia o mesmo princípio
pegar a átomo por átomo molécula por
molécula e assim por diante até
construir um objeto físico e escala
macrométrica
bom pra encurtar essa história para
terminar essa história
exatos 20 anos depois de lido o livro do
drexler
eu imprimi isso aqui não faz milagre
usando uma impressora 3d
foi um momento que eu vi um objeto
físico o que eu tinha modelada no
computador
saindo visita à mente de uma piscina de
um tanque de resina que eu pensei que o
futuro de fato tinha chegado num esse
tipo de impressão não é exatamente o
mesmo que aconteciam na piscina do texas
mas a questão é que a gente está no
caminho eu queria explicar por que há
cinco anos atrás a the economist
publicou uma matéria que diz que a gente
está passando pela terceira revolução
industrial a da digitalização da
produção e isso só é possível por conta
da disseminação da do crescimento
exponencial das tecnologias digitais
mas o que tem de novo nessa terceira
revolução industrial o que ela tem de
mais importante eu queria passar com
vocês rapidamente os últimos 200 anos
das revoluções industriais e cinco
minutos vamos lá a primeira revolução
industrial na passagem do século 18 para
19 homem conseguiu mecanizar o trabalho
braçal com as máquinas a vapor
além do impacto enorme que isso teve a
humanidade positivo e também trouxe
outros impactos negativos que eu queria
salientar dois deles da urbanização
desenfreada ea poluição em alguns
lugares da inglaterra era impossível
enxergar o sol devido à quantidade de
fumaça que saía pelas chaminés
continuando a nossa história no final do
século 19 henry ford ii visitou um
matadouro uma linha de desmontagem e
teve a idéia de inverter o processo e
com isso ele simplesmente inaugurou a
segunda revolução industrial da linha de
montagem imóvel e da produção em série
a gente continuou com os mesmos
problemas da primeira revolução
industrial mas apareceram outros
a gente pode dizer que ali nascia a
alienação trabalhador que passava horas
e horas em turnos enorme de trabalho
fazendo tarefas repetitivas em prol do
aumento
são mas o fato é que a produção em série
virou um novo paradigma e milhões e
milhões de automóveis do modelo t saíram
de mais precisamente uns 15 milhões
sairão de detroit para o mundo um bom
esses carros todos agora precisava achar
os compradores e aí tem um outro
subproduto da segunda revolução
industrial que eu particularmente acho
que é tão nocivo o mais nocivo que a
poluição que a propaganda
nasce aí a profissionalização da
propaganda e do marketing que perdi a
inocência de simplesmente descrever as
qualidades dos seus produtos para passar
a ter como objetivo principal criar
desejo onde não há necessidade
coincidentemente a gente acabou de
passar pela black friday ontem e vendo
aquelas pessoas tomam se acotovelando
pra comprar produtos que não precisam
há um desconto que não existe dá pra
dizer que a gente continua bem
influenciado pelo marketing mesmo mais
de cem anos depois enfim terminar esse
resumo no final do século 20 a gente
conseguiu otimizar a produção em série
de uma forma que era inimaginável para o
reino é forte mas apesar da aparente
modernidade dessa imagem cheia de robôs
o que mudou de fato na renascença na
indústria nos últimos 100 anos
a gente pegou a poluição da desigualdade
o desenvolvimento urbano acelerado e
descontrolado a alienação empacotou seu
nome bacana de externalidade que é
basicamente a diferença entre o preço
que o próprio mercado paga por um
produto eo seu custo social real não
deixar mais fácil de entender a gente
poderia trocar aquele gráfico bacana por
essa imagem aqui em determinada idade é
o termo que foi inventado para dizer
onde está o custo da existência de um
lugar como esse das milhares de pessoas
que vivem aí no meio do lixo tem um
outro exemplo ainda queria deixar mais
claro para vocês vocês acham que uma
coisa que gasta tudo isso de energia e
de material para ser produzida pode ter
esse preço
ou seja quem está pagando essa diferença
de custo
quem está pagando é o planeta é meio
piegas falar isso mas é verdade que está
pagando a conta é o planeta
só que a carteira dele está meio vazia e
essa conta que não fecha está voltando
pra todos nós
o motivo mais óbvio o exemplo mais óbvio
são as mudanças climáticas que a gente
está passando em função do aquecimento
global
nessa altura deve estar se perguntando
com mais essa impressão 3d a palestra
que está falando aqui de outras coisas
catástrofe aquecimento global em si
mesmo pois é eu queria chegar nesse
fundo do poço aqui com vocês pra gente
poder tentar entender o panorama e poder
pensar juntos o que a gente pode fazer
de melhor com as novas tecnologias de
construção disse que a gente já tem
disponível a terceira revolução
industrial
é aquela que traz a digitalização da
produção ou seja ela faz isso é uma
mudança de paradigma real
a gente passa da produção em massa para
a customização em massa o que isso
significa que vamos lembrar que para
fazer um produto em série
normalmente eu preciso de máquinas
grandes e caras que de um lado e
trabalham que trabalham é fazendo a
mesma tarefa repetidamente geralmente
baseadas em moldes é esses moldes essas
máquinas são geralmente muito caras o
que tem e que isso tem duas implicações
a primeira que você perder muito
dinheiro para industrial e ter acesso a
esses meios de produção ea segunda que
você precisa produzir milhares e
milhares de peças iguais de qualquer
coisa que você faça com que o custo de
aquisição seja minimamente razoável na
fabricação digital isso não acontece
porque o trabalho com informação e não
mais com o molde físico
a máquina pode fazer objetos diferentes
e essa é a grande sacada a impressão 3d
nada mais é do que é uma vedete das
tecnologias que já existem por aí na
indústria mais de 50 anos
o que acontece aqui por conta da
miniaturização do barateamento das
tecnologias passaram a ficar mais
acessíveis ao público em geral dá um
exemplo uma fresadora cnc que em 1959
ocupava um andar inteiro no haiti
custava alguns milhões de dólares
hoje pode ser operada por qualquer
pessoa
sou na garagem da sua casa uma
impressora 3d por exemplo tanto faz
fazer sem xícaras iguais ou sem chifres
diferentes ou sem objetos diferentes
porque ela não trabalha com o molde a
trabalha com informação a única coisa
que importa pra essas máquinas é o tempo
gasto no trabalho material que ela
utiliza eu posso uma primeira impressão
fazer por exemplo três vasos diferentes
uma segunda impressão eu posso fazer uma
prótese de mão totalmente funcional
essa flexibilização essa flexibilidade
dessas máquinas é comum a todas as
máquinas de fabricação digital
elas possuem um fluxo de trabalho
semelhante que eu vou explicar aqui pra
vocês como funciona com um exemplo da
nossa luminária aqui a primeira coisa
que eu fiz foi modelar esse objeto num
programa de computador de modelagem
tridimensional
aí você pensa bons arquitetos sabe mexer
nesses programas e eu não sei mexer não
sei como é que eu posso fazer isso daí
mas não é bem assim hoje em dia tem uma
série de programas de modelagem
tridimensional alguns muito fácil alguns
até voltados para crianças estão
disponíveis a um custo muito baixo até
gratuitamente
então ou seja dá para aprender sim a
trabalhar mesmo que você não queira você
pode acessar uma das plataformas online
disponível que tem por aí onde as
pessoas simplesmente fazem seus projetos
e disponibilizam os produtos prontos
para download é só você baixar e
construir voltando pra nossa época o
nosso produto eu pego esses esse objeto
que eu desenhei no cat que é o desenho
auxiliado por computador e coloca um
outro software que é o canto ea
manufatura auxiliado por computador
nesse momento eu vou dizer o computador
todas as informações de fabricação que
eu tenho necessidade de colocar então
por exemplo eu disse pra ele qual que a
madeira que está utilizando a espessura
dessa maneira qualquer a fresno a
ferramenta de corte que eu vou utilizar
qualquer velocidade de corte em função
da madeira que o trabalhando enfim estou
literalmente programando a minha
fabricação
nesse momento do programa lembra da
história do ego e do mundo
elas inglês drexler é uma coisa parecida
mas a gente ainda está falando em escala
macroscópica a partir desse ponto o
kanji era um arquivo digital chamado g
code que nada mais é do que uma série de
instruções que vai dizer para a máquina
quando se mover onde e à qual velocidade
depois de todo esse processo
eu simplesmente vou mandar isso para a
máquina e ela vai simplesmente executar
esse código de forma a que no final
desse processo eu vou ter ou um produto
pronto por exemplo no caso de uma
impressão 3d ou no caso do que a gente
tem aqui uma série de peças prontas que
eu posso simplesmente montar parece
banal mas o impacto disso tudo é enorme
imagina que uma pessoa do outro lado do
planeta quisesse iluminar igual a essa
na manufatura tradicional eu tenho que
fazer isso daqui localmente e mandar
isso é pra outro lado do mundo
fisicamente imaginam esse custo às vezes
é maior do que o custo de produção da
peça fora o custo ambiental de mandar
isso daí
daqui até o outro lado do planeta como a
gente está falando de um arquivo digital
de fabricação digital eu simplesmente
envia um arquivo para lá na china pega
esse arquivo vai ter um make space
fábrica sua própria luminária ou se
preferir terceiriza isso um serviço
terceirizado de corte por exemplo
isso é possível devido à disseminação
desses espaços de fabricação digital pra
gente falar só de uma rede dos fab labs
já são mais de 1.200 espalhados pelo
mundo e aqui no brasil são mais de 46
mil espécies ou fab labs são espaços
onde as pessoas podem ter acesso a essas
ferramentas de fabricação digital de uma
maneira fácil e rápida e com isso tirar
suas próprias idéias do papel
apesar dessas máquinas todas serem
maravilhosas o impacto o aspecto que eu
gostaria de salientar da terceira
revolução industrial é o impacto disso
no consumo saber ou conhecer como as
coisas são feitas te dá um poder
impressionante
isso não significa que agora a gente vai
passar a fabricar tudo que a gente
consome utiliza mas tem esse
conhecimento faz com que a gente possa
na
izar escolher melhor o que a gente
consome
eu brinco que têm esse conhecimento não
faz você não comprar mais absolutamente
nada por impulso
a minha brincadeira que essa é uma
espécie de maldição maker
quando eu preciso comprar alguma coisa
primeira coisa que eu faço é pensar se
eu não podia fazer aquilo que não posso
fazer eu penso se vale o dinheiro que
eles estão me pedindo e nesse meio tempo
eu acabo nem fazendo nem comprando o que
significa que é bom eu não precisava
mesmo daquilo lá
o planeta agradece a minha história não
tem nada que obrigue a gente a comprar
uma coisa que a gente não precisa o que
causa algum mal do planeta
nada se a gente parar de comprar o que a
gente não precisa as empresas não vão
simplesmente sumiu desaparecer
elas vão achar novas e melhores maneiras
de fazer os seus produtos e agradar seus
clientes que esse é o papel das empresas
por isso é importante se perguntar onde
é que vem a minha roupa a comida que eu
como e onde é que vêm os móveis da minha
casa
será que eles são produzidos de maneira
sustentável onde se tem uma série de
internalizar a dis também embutidas
nisso daí eu tenho certeza que o
consumismo é uma palavra atrasado é uma
realidade ultrapassada que a gente vai
ter vergonha disso
muito em breve assim como foi com a
escravidão a gente não chegou ainda no
ponto imaginado por trechos por onde
toda a produção mais limpa e sob demanda
mas enquanto isso não chega é uma
questão de pouco tempo
é importante a gente poder participar
desse processo de democratização da
informação ou democratização da produção
para que a gente possa participar mais
ativamente e conquistar aí o bem mais
essencial que a gente precisa para viver
neste mundo conturbado de hoje esse bem
ele não é um bem material
e se bem é a consciência trazendo
fabricando e montando esse objeto aqui
pra vocês eu quis é mostrar como é fácil
e poder participar ativamente desse
processo de fabricação das coisas e com
isso participar de forma mais ativa e
consciente
eu espero ter trazido alguma luz pra
vocês em meu desejo é que a gente possa
junto
o de mudar o mundo em que a gente vive
utilizando essas tecnologias
obrigado
[Aplausos]